[Music]
thanks for coming out
no thanks for having me I I feel like
we've done four or five podcasts and
then I realize you've only been on the
show once is it once I thought it was
twice maybe it was yeah you're right
yeah I think it is it has been twice but
it does feel like I've I don't know
we've talked a lot
oh yeah it's a microphone so which is
like the opposite I have with most
people I feel like I only get to see
them write a podcast and it's the only
time we talk for like three yes in a row
your entire relationship with somebody's
[ __ ] podcast which is increasingly my
relationship with my wife well I like
that's what I liked about the one that
you did with your dad I was like I've
never had that conversation yeah because
you never would you do you never do it
it's it's something that that we
probably think a lot about like oh
when's that day gonna come and I'm gonna
sit down I'm gonna you know we're gonna
have a scotch and you know talk about
your life and that moment never really
arises and it had occurred to me that I
wanted to do that and I wanted there's
something about putting a microphone in
somebody that in front of somebody that
creates a formality and a structure yeah
that kind of allows that to transpire
because it forces the person to actually
think about what they're gonna say with
the idea that I would never probably
never share it yeah but then when he
wrote the book and it was like okay we
can do this yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
appreciate all the support and the help
that you've lent to him in his book it's
no I mean I told you I would have done
it anyway because I thought it was a
really good book and I thought it was
important yeah it's funny you told me
the story of meeting my dad yeah sure
one of your book signing things and he
just like rolled right up to you right
before you were supposed to speak right
I don't I don't know if it was right
before right after but it was I remember
we texted about it oh I get I recognize
some of my dad in your debt uh-huh and
yeah it was funny yeah well the occasion
of this podcast is is your new book
which we're gonna get into in a minute
which I loved I think it's fantastic I
really this is like right in my
wheelhouse like I just love it
but before we get into that like I
wanted to spend at least a couple
minutes talking about
this other part of of what you do I mean
you're in LA because you were down
speaking with the Rams right and
something that you've been doing more
and more of it seems like every week
you're at another major league sports
franchise well this is an unusual set of
two weeks but yes last week I was with
the Browns and I got to speak to the
team and and avid and I spent a couple
days with them that was very cool they I
was most excited they let me swim in the
team I saw a pool Wow and so it's it's
at field level so you can watch prac
you're basically looking at the ankles
of the players going through
walkthroughs in practice as you're
swimming right so and they only let me
use the pool when the players were
practicing because then they wouldn't be
there so that was really cool and then I
happen to know the the GM of the Rams
and he invited me out and so I spoke to
the coaches but yesterday Holliday and
what is that what's that like like when
you're talking to the talk to the
players as well or is it mainly the Rams
I didn't
I've spoken to different teams like it
before it's a very weird audience the
the weirdest audience was so in March I
spoke at the NFL owners meeting uh-huh
which was probably the most unusual
audience that I'll ever speak to I mean
aside from maybe addressing the UN like
when would you have this aggregation of
billionaires yeah I mean so it's a
minimum of 32 billionaires and then it
was all the head coaches and all of the
team presidents and all of the GM's and
so it was just it's just a surreal
audience I mean it's like it's humbling
to be there but then you're just like I
think what what strikes me is I was like
I'm talking these people about ancient
philosophy this is like us I think
that's so cool and it's also so absurd
at the same time well I mean certainly
when you sat down to you know write
these books this series of books you
could not have predicted or imagined
that it would have been embraced in this
you know sort of subculture to the
extent that it has I mean it would have
been delusional is the only word but it
it does make sense like there's a bunch
of Stokes who were athletes I think what
I try to do
the bookses apply ancient wisdom to life
in a practical way and I think I think I
would like to think I'm not just like
hey here's how you get through the day
but I want to say like hey what is what
are the really smart people throughout
history figured out about being elite at
whatever you do whether that's being
elite as a human being or a parent or
you know an athlete or a leader or
whatever but it's just it's just really
cool I like it it's just I just really
like I like talking to all different
audiences but it's certainly much more
interesting to address a sports team
that you've watched on television that
it that it's sort of struggle bumping up
against the limits of like human
performance sight than it is to talk to
an insurance company not that I don't
like talking to the insurance company
but there's just there's a purity to
sports that I'm interested in because
like like when you I don't know just all
the cliches that if a normal person said
you'd be like that's lame an athlete can
say in a locker room after a game and it
has been it is like they really mean it
they're not like bullshitting you know
like they really are they really do
speak in these sort of like cliches and
and epigrams because it's and I talked a
little bit about this in the book but
you know Yogi Berra had that line like
it's impossible the thing can hit at the
same time right
so it's sports because your body's doing
most of the work you have to simplify
the mental it's a gift to simmer the
sauce down to its absolute essence huh
and so it's just so simple and
straightforward and there's no like
irony or [ __ ] or you know posturing
in sport is just there well I think
there's a difference between a group of
executives who all want to perform but
fundamentally it's a job right yeah it's
different from an athlete but it's their
job as well but the the level of
receptivity to finding that extra edge
to game performance I think is probably
much more heightened in that community
yeah and you know hearing you say that I
would say the only other group where
you're like these are all the best
people in the world
at what they do and they're on the same
team would be like the military like
there would never be there's no audience
there's no like hey these are the 30
best writers in the world and somehow
they're on the same team sitting in the
same room and you can address them do
you know it because everything else is
like one-on-one combat like the rest of
the work like my books have spread
through sports because like like a guy
at the that the thing I talked to you
today it was telling me he'd read the
book and I said how did you hear about
it and he told him this was not like a
high level guy this is just a guy he's
like oh the GM of this other NFL team
told me I should read it right the CEO
of Google does not recommend books to
anyone let alone like the people at
rival companies uh-huh and so there's
just that it's just a unique thing where
he's like all these people are like on
the same team trying to get better
together there's just a coolness that I
don't there's no other audience where
you get to do yeah so as somebody who
wrote a book called ego is the enemy and
that's got to be a challenge to keep
your ego in check when somebody says
something like that to you yeah you know
cuz that's that's heavy man yeah I mean
I would I would I try to remind myself
is is know these people care like
they're like you're just like you're
talking to the players and they're just
like if you gives me something I can use
I'll use them and then I'll immediately
forget who he is like the next week
somebody else is coming in yeah yeah
exactly and and it's also good to just
remind yourself of like success in our
field is like the rookie minimum
contract in the NFL right do you know
what it like like you're just like oh
this is it's humbling just to be you're
like I'm in your world but I'm not of
your world right so I that's what I try
to focus on what is the most surreal
experience that you've had kind of
navigating that terrain that's a good
question I mean it's like you'll get
Wrecking likes everyone's will get
recognized like in and it's like I'm
supposed to be going the other direction
uh-huh you know what I mean like that's
that's uh that's weird
I don't know it I think the weirdest
thing about the sports stuff is everyone
smile just get like an email from a head
coach or GM or something and you're just
like even at that level these are just
normal people reading books and then
shooting a note to the author right they
like them right like it's still pretty
normal I know that's that that's the
surreal experience you just wake up no I
tell what is that that from who I think
that is from like I just wanted to like
chat you know well in addition to to
athletes and sports franchises I mean
your your writing has been embraced by
Silicon Valley like these other
subcultures that are really steeped in
in you know that that like fine edge of
performance and and generally just how
to live a more meaningful life and do it
in a you know in a grounded strategic
and fundamentally rewarding way I hope
so yeah so stillness is the evolution of
this process and I and I say evolution
very mindfully like I think it really is
in certain ways it's synthesis of your
other books and it's also you know a
very natural next chapter and certainly
your most spiritual book yes so I'm
interested in how you arrived at the
decision to tackle this subject matter
and why this became your next book yeah
I mean I think stillness the idea of
stillness not like I'm not referring to
the book but the ideas that that concept
of stillness it struck me is like when
you remove ego stillness emerges you
need stillness to overcome these kinds
of obstacles so it was sort of it's sort
of the glue that got went unsaid in the
other books and and so I was I just kept
coming back to this idea and when you
look at really great people whether
they're athletes or generals or just
like a wise person that you met or
you're a grandfather what they all seem
to have is that you I just cuz I'm not a
still person I'm like a high energy
person you probably hear it through the
microphone like I move my arms a lot you
know I'm like that kind of person so
when I meet someone who's like
well you're just like operating on a
different plane yeah that like
unflappable yeah you know groundedness
it almost seems archaic because it is so
rare that you now meet somebody of that
kind of stature yes and what's
interesting is that basically and this
is what inspired the book is that like
basically any and all of the ancient
schools have their are talked about that
idea in their own way as the sort of
like the end goal of what we're doing
yeah it's a consistent thread that
you'll find in every philosophy and
every religion fundamentally which is
something that that you explore but like
stoicism and Epicureanism are supposed
to be opposite philosophies huh and yet
like the Stoics talk about apatheia and
the Epicureans talk about ataraxia yeah
i wrote down all those words and I can
only pronounce a few of them yeah as
Lama hitch Steve Ott hitched a vote
yes cemaat mom I just went through all
of them to record the audio book but I
was just in that those two it's like
wait they have these are opposite
philosophies they have the same idea and
basically very similar words you're just
like whoa how does that hat and then you
realize oh that's just what we're all
working towards everybody is trying
everyone wants to be calmer and more in
control and less like heart beating out
of their chest at the whim of their
emotions our insecurities and and and
that we need it not only at like the
personal level but also we know that's
where our best like professional work
comes from and so that I was just
fascinated with that and it's also
something I have no natural inclination
toward right so I try to also try to
write for what I'm reaching towards
mm-hmm I wasn't writing the egos the
enemy because I don't have an ego
it's really opposite of that and and
again you make this conscious decision
to not really inject your own personal
narrative into the narrative of the book
I mean you have the epilogue at the end
where you tell a little story but other
than that you really remove yourself
from it yeah my regret
my editor disagrees but my regret on ego
is that it be like that I that I'm even
in that book I would rather not don't
what is that I don't know I don't know I
think there's a certain timelessness
that comes with removing like it becomes
a text yes that will withstand the test
of time perhaps a little bit better if
you take your own that's what I think I
think it helped the book in the short
term and then every year that goes by it
feels a little weirder even cuz like
that's not where I am like it it feels
like it dates it to where I was when I
was writing it which I get and I've
heard wonderful things from people who
appreciate that but I don't know I just
I'm trying I the book to me the I did
write the books but I almost could read
them and enjoy them because I feel like
what I'm doing is channelling and
explaining other people and other
people's ideas primarily and I'm just
arranging them and they're all things
that are part and parcel of what it
means to be a human struggling so no
matter how far down you are this path or
where you are in your evolution we all
stumble and it's always it's always
going to be relevant to be able to go
back to something that you're struggling
and find a passage in one of your books
it's gonna be apropos yeah and and that
was another thing I you asked me how do
you prevent the stuff from going to your
head I've realized to like someone every
once well like actually this happened
when I was at Cleveland like one of the
coaches showed me his copy of obstacle
or know of ego and it was literally like
a hundred percent underlined like you've
gone through multiple times a hundred
percent underlined almost every page you
know folded and and there's a moment
where I go I can't believe I did that
like and I was like because I read books
and I do that to books and here's
someone doing it back to me and then I
realized that's actually the same fact
this book is an accumulation of all the
things that I underlined in other books
so of course it's filled with underlines
it's not that it's not like she's
underlining these brilliant original
sentences for me
he's underlining the quote that I had
underlined in another book and then
built my book around do you know what I
mean yeah
stand that I mean your your role you're
very clear in your writing and it makes
you know these ideas which are difficult
to grapple with very digestible but
you're almost beyond the actual pros
like you're curating a way for people to
emotionally connect with these truths by
choosing which stories best illustrate
them and and trying to find stories that
also will withstand the test of time
yeah and like I think some people think
like like I was actually a note i get
from my editor sometimes where she's
like you know people don't know who this
is and I'm like what do you mean like I
like I'm referring to them by their
first name or something because like I'm
so familiar with that work I just like
assume like everyone's heard this story
like 30 times
yeah well this goes back to my theory I
don't know if I've actually told you
that's my favorite my ride holiday
theory yeah is that you were born out of
time yes you should have been born like
you're a guy who should have been
storming the beaches at Normandy
well I glad that that didn't happen I
thought I didn't have to but you have
the sensibility of like the great
generation you know what I mean you're
very interested in in history and you're
fascinated by things that like my
grandfather was fat that are that are
increasingly rare for somebody of your
age which makes you like kind of
pleasantly anachronistic yeah yes sure
so you know do you know Jordan Harbinger
yes so I'm gonna put I know I'm delaying
but so he's all right no this is like
how you this is also how you get cut
down to size which is always good so I
was telling him about the book or
something and he this is what he said
let me find it was so good she said I
was like hey do you want me to send you
the new book and he's like oh I think I
heard about he's like is that the book
that includes famous historical
personalities and how they apply it so
principles to hard times or something
like that and I was like and he was like
being nice but I was like oh like was
that just like a super sick burn of like
like summarizing like my entire career
because that's like all my books justice
crazy is that the one where you you take
you tell stories about famous people
filled with lots of quotes from other
famous people and it was like yeah yeah
you're right
that's what I think but in this book
going back to the evolution like you
can't tackle stillness without dipping
your toe in in Eastern philosophy right
so this is like your first adventure in
that direction that was much all new for
me yes and and you know in the Venn
diagram there's there's a lot of overlap
and how these you know these ideas are
synergistic but what I found interesting
is that most books that would tackle
this subject matter or either they're
gonna fall into two categories there's
gonna be New Age books books about how
to meditate or about mindfulness from
that kind of perspective or they're
gonna be very science oriented like yeah
the the neurology you know the the
neurology what's like steeped in all the
studies that prove that you should be
meditating and all of that and you
really stayed clear of both of those
worlds and I'm wondering whether you
felt compelled at times to you know
bring in like what you know Matthew
Walker has to say about sleep or you
know what these you know studies are
showing about what happens in our brains
when we can be still totally it was a
weird thing so I like you have Dan
Harris book meted writing for fidgety
skeptics and I love him I think he's
great but like even that it's like even
they're saying it's perfidy skeptics
it's for people like you or me I think
most people are like nope you know what
it's like but I don't I don't even know
does the word meditation even appear
once in this book it appears in passing
but on purpose I never say you should
meditate one because I don't I just like
can't I can't do it but I've I've you'd
rather tell a story about Churchill and
how he likes to go on long walks that's
yes but but my point is like that I
think people go people like I hear that
Eastern stuff is really great but every
time I hear about they're like telling
me to meditate and I can't meditate I
don't meditate that is what I think most
people think so like that's aweso table
for me and I think my what I try to do
in the book is go there's a whole bunch
of really great stuff from the Eastern
people that you can benefit for well
before you have to like just sit quietly
with your own
or no thoughts yeah and and the other
thing is like I think like the truth is
we live in the West and so I think one
of the reasons that the eastern stuff
doesn't work for people is that it seems
like it's for a totally different world
and so what I wanted to do is go like
how can I apply the eastern insights in
a Western like format so it's like you
learn by stories we tend to learn by
personality like I think one of the
reasons that Eastern stuff is
intimidating to people and to me too is
like I've never heard of any of these
names so I don't know like like when
someone hears Marcus Aurelius - like oh
that's that cool guy from the movie
Gladiator like he was the Emperor I want
to be king you know like and then you
hear a thing about Confucius and your
life what was that it was like some
wandering guy like in a robe should I
listen to him like and so I wanted to
take the insights but then which is what
I did with with stoicism in the first
two books so I want to take these ideas
and then illustrate them with stories of
people that most people want to be like
so you get the essence of the lesson
rather than going like oh I'm just
supposed to I'm supposed to abandon the
idea of having the self I'm supposed to
get rid of all my possessions because
some name I can't pronounce you know
said it was a good idea and then like
people who were yoga pants to talk about
it a lot you know yeah I get it no I get
it but one of the things you've
succeeded at is making this ancient
philosophy stoicism like cool like
people are all about it like it's groovy
to be a stoic and somebody maybe it's
you maybe it's somebody else needs to do
the same for some of these archetypes
from the Eastern traditions because I
think with the right storytelling
somebody could very easily accomplish
that yeah I think we get caught up in
the language and these people we don't
know and the and the kind of asceticism
of it all yeah it just becomes
unrelatable but if you actually read the
bhagavad-gita like it's talking warriors
yeah they're like total badasses and
what they're doing the stories are
insane yeah we like we think oh the
Odyssey is cool like you Odysseus he's a
badass he's like a warriors fighting
he's doing I was the Bhagavad
Ghita is basically the same poem yeah
you know it's the same it's teaching the
same lessons but it seems like this
there's I assume I would there's
probably a certain amount of racism
where we think it's like soft and for
pansies and it's like we think one is
like a poem but the Odyssey is a cool
story and that's because we've seen like
a bunch of movies and there's other
stuff about one and not about the other
so I yeah I was trying to make them
accessible right well in terms of the
launching off kind of point for the book
you know contextually right now we're in
a culture in which you know we've never
been more starved of our ability to be
still like we're in this crazy
attention-deficit era of unprecedented
proportions I mean you talk about the
CNN effect but you know we're in the CNN
effect on steroids like it's a sure way
crazier than just news being on
television 24 hours a day and it's
become increasingly more and more
difficult to put the phone down and
spend you know one minute with ourselves
sure and we tend to think of this as you
know a modern epidemic and I thought it
was really cool that you open the book
with this story of Seneca and you
realize like oh this isn't like this has
been going on forever like this guy had
the exact same problem that I had this
morning yes yeah there's and actually
I'd written the book without that I
started with so I started with the
Lincoln story that's originally where
the book was gonna open there was a
story about Lincoln saying there's this
city that's a key and that the Civil War
can't be won without the key and so it's
like oh that's the title of the book
stillness is the key that's was gonna be
around and I sent it early draft of it
to Robert Greene and he was like I
really like it but I feel like you have
to like glued it and where we are right
now which is amazing advice and he was
like isn't there this letter from Seneca
where he's like in Rome and he's like
describing exactly how noisy and loud it
is and sounds exactly like a modern city
and I was like yeah I think there is let
me don't look for that and I found it
and I was like exactly I was probably in
a hotel room when I found it it's noisy
I got a bunch of and Seneca just he's
writing to his friend
and he's basically he's like it's so
loud outside my window that I wish I was
deaf you know and he's descript he's
staying above a gym basically and he's
like these people are dropping weights
and there's people splashing in the pool
there was a guy getting arrested
downstairs like you're just like it it
sounds it sounded like a summer
afternoon in New York City right when
you just want to blow your brains out
because it's so loud yeah and and he's
like but I'm trying to work and I and
and he describes that stoic state that
apatheia where like that equanimity
where you're you manage to tune it all
out and you kind of go into that flow
state and you do what you have to do and
that's what stillness is to me stillness
isn't like the monk who renounces all
his possessions and of course is still
because he's on a you know a ten year
meditation retreat and the beautiful you
know
Buddhist monastery in the mountains it's
like oh you can get this anywhere and in
fact it's harder to get in real life but
that's where it's most valuable yeah the
mastery is in taking it into the world
and we are somebody like Seneca or a
fortune 500 executive or a quarterback
you're shouldering tremendous
responsibility and pressure and there's
a lot of external stimuli that's vying
for your attention and the mastery is in
trying to figure out what's important
and what's not and and and being you
know able to focus on what is key
actually in moving you forward on the
trajectory that that you know you're
here to do yes yeah that's exactly right
and that's why the people who can do it
either produce this sort of stunning
things that take our breath away or get
paid all the money because like no one
else can do it it's really hard and it
was refreshing to hear Seneca like you
know sort of struggling with this
grappling with it in real time yes
because we think of him as somebody who
has mastered these when what I liked
about the Seneca stories it's not just
hey this guy has some ability to tune
out the noise because what if you're
sensitive it's like also his personal
life is collapse everything's falling
apart
everything's so it is also going like
you're saying the other
all these outside noises but oftentimes
the noise is in your head it's you or
than or it's in your you've got some
spiritual malady that's causing and so
it's that he's able to do it on all the
fronts at the same time and clear and
clear it and get and I don't think I
don't think stillness is this I think
the other things people think still
missus maybe that idea if Nirvana out
like you get there and then you're there
I think it's it's like can you get it
for 20 minutes mm-hmm and what can you
do in the 20 minutes that you have you
know what I mean it's like it's talking
about football it's like the stillness
that New England has down being being
down 28 to 3 in the Super Bowl and just
stringing together four or five drives
in 12 minutes to pull off this thing the
high maybe the high-water mark of the
entire game and then you go back to
regular life and you you dream about
getting back there sometime do you know
what I mean yeah yeah you just have
these moments where it all comes
together and I think the book and what
I've been thinking a lot about is how do
you build a life how do you build habits
how to build systems how do you build a
practice that lets you get there every
once in a while because when you do it's
just magical and that's where all the
good stuff comes from yeah there's
there's gentle reminders throughout the
book that these people weren't born this
way and for most of their lives they
weren't this way we tend to look at
somebody who exudes those qualities and
just think like wow it would be cool to
be like that but I have no idea how to
do that
they're just that's the way they are but
you're saying you're kind of nudging
people towards this realization that no
these are this is very accessible yeah
may be fleeting it's a practice well
like so I tell the story in the book of
Kennedy and the Cuban Missile Crisis and
there's sort of no one I think who
embodies what we're talking about more
than Kennedy in the sense that he got
there and yet also was the opposite of
that all the time and then also like
when I'd think about writing that
chapter like I you and I went for a run
in Malibu like almost exactly a year ago
as I just read all the stuff
I was trying to put it together and you
and I were talking on a run and I would
say a good chunk of that chapter came
together from us doing some sort of
physical activity talking like that
chapter wasn't it wasn't like that just
magically came to me and I got it right
the first time it was like it was just a
bunch of different sort of flashes of
getting there through different things
like and and it came together over time
and I shaped it and and but it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't a function of
willfulness it was a function of letting
go
which is a big another big theme in
totally like surrendering and you know
finding the ability to be present so
that these ideas can like congeal in
your mind and present themselves more
fully formed yeah yeah yeah it wasn't
like some sprint of genius that I pulled
out that chapter it was like a lot of
quiet time reading and it was time doing
this and time doing that and times just
sitting there and and just putting
putting in the work and eventually you
get there and hopefully there's some
insight that resonates with someone and
helps them do something a lot of no
cards a lot of fun what do you what do
you do with the note cards when you
finished a book so they all get scanned
in case there's a fire and then I lose
them
and then I just they're there it's like
you have that book is the raw material
or that that box of cards is the raw
material and I I mean they're all just
sort of not displayed but they're
sitting there in my office it's actually
really good because it's like oh I
remember what I what I do when I look at
those boxes because now I have you know
for each one of these there's one each
one of my books is like this box is
their own box it's like I remember
taking that box out of the packaging
uh-huh and there was nothing and that's
what a book is a book is filling that in
yeah so there's a tactile element to it
yeah just or it's just like it's a
manifestation of the process it's like
it's like if you run up a mountain
you're like I remember being at the
bottom of that mountain
you know fright and and so it's like I
remember when
zero notecards mhm and now there's 2000
note cards and so when I'm starting the
next book it's like okay it always
starts at zero put the stuff together
and I've got enough boxes sitting over
there to know that I can do this again
yes and I also the other thing is the
boxes because I've talked about them I
don't think they make them anymore that
price is like shot way up on Amazon so I
have like ten so I like it's almost like
in a way like I can flash forward to the
end of my career like maybe I'll get to
these but it's just like that's like my
whole life right yeah so they're just
sort of gently in the back reminding you
that there's more books or just like if
you could get if if I was like rich
you'll have six more cars in your
lifetime and they're parked in this
parking lot over here and you'll go
through one after another it's like it's
a weird manifestation kind of home it's
a it's yeah reminder of your mortality
too and and just the ephemerality of all
of it right you know what I mean like
I'm so I'm gonna fill these boxes and
then okay that'll be my life yeah yeah
yeah well back to Kennedy
um he's great he encapsulates you know
so much of of what this book is about in
that he demonstrates his ability to to
be still and navigate the Cuban Missile
Crisis with you know the weight of the
the planet essentially hanging in the
balance and he gets he gets you know
everybody through that experience but
he's also a guy who started out as a
dilettante and you know has all these
family issues his dad and bottom of you
would surprise basically there's all
these he didn't he didn't start as this
magnificent statesman yeah and then
later in the book you kind of revisit
him through all his sexcapades yeah and
you realize like oh this guy is yes he
has this moment where he's able to step
up and do this but he also is very human
and and flawed in in many other ways
yeah it's like during so during the
Cuban Missile Crisis his photo of him
and he's leaning over the like so you
see him from the back so it's like that
famous
I mean he's like standing there like
this and you can tell it I mean just
imagine think if I was like rich I need
you to come up with a solution to this
problem and if you don't sixty million
people died probably including you and
your family you know like just the the
weight of that and and for him and
everybody's pushing you to make this one
decision that you're not sure is right
the and worse there it's a very
satisfying Lee primal and justifiable
thing that they're asking me to do do
you know what I mean they're like don't
get pushed around and you're like I
don't want to get pushed around you know
like they're they're telling him to do
something that would be very seductive
and natural like they brought Lyndon
Johnson into the room in Linda's oh we
got a bomb to [ __ ] our cue but you know
like it's just that's just weird
and so he resists that and it's so
impressive and yet during one of the 13
days he asks someone on his staff to
drive down this like girl from a liberal
arts college and then he has sex with
her in a White House arena in a DC hotel
yeah she was 19 yeah it's gross I mean
it's just super gross and so it's it's
is that just grosses like a man
basically preying on a small you know
the most powerful man in the world like
using his power to you know manipulate a
young girl but it's like for all he knew
this could be like his last night on the
planet and he's not a small choice that
he's making yeah he's not with
Jacqueline and the kids mm-hmm you know
it's like I just when I read that I was
like what were they doing did he tell
them like did they know and he was just
pretending he was at work did not even
care it just made me feel very sad so
how do you reconcile like this great
moment where he's able to you know make
a decision that changes the trajectory
of history with you know the foibles of
his personal life so that's like a
criticism I got with my books my answer
is like I don't reconcile them like
people will go like oh you know Ryan you
know virtue is the highest aim and
stoicism and yet in you know the
obstacles away you're telling a story
about Earl and Rommel who was you know a
Nazi general or Samuel Zimmer is like
this basically
robber baron who you know rapes Central
and South America as the CEO of United
Fruit I'm not saying you should be like
John Kennedy the person I'm saying you
should be like John Kennedy in the Cuban
Missile Crisis doing this one thing in
the same way that we with you when you
draw an analogy to something you're not
like or if you say like oh this person's
fast like a horse you're not saying like
also you know they're just like [ __ ]
uncontrollably all over like it's not a
it's not a complete analogy or metaphor
it's it's the capturing the essence of
this one thing in isolation the idea of
the book is like there's here's a bunch
of people doing the right thing in the
right moment can you as a person put
them together
why can you put the goodness of Kennedy
here and the the goodness of so-and-so
here and the goodness of so-and-so here
and avoid the the trap the Tiger Woods
fell in or you know so the idea is like
can you grab a collection of all of the
virtues of these people and avoid the
vices that either them or other people
fell prey to and come up with like a new
combination yeah yeah yeah
well I think it was a good and important
choice to show that you know the rounded
humanity of these people because if you
only show the good thing then you are
opening yourself up to that kind of
criticism and we're in a culture right
now we're you know we're judging
everybody on their worst actions and
deciding that they need to be erased
from the record forever yeah and and
look one of the reasons I liked Tiger I
like I learned this from Robert Greene
is like you don't just show people
observing the laws or like what you're
trying to say you also show the costs or
the the downsides of violating right
like in the 48 laws of power its
observance of the law a transgression of
the law
like it you're shown both and so someone
like a Tiger Woods was someone who had
this intense mental discipline but had a
spiritual bankruptcy and the idea is
that if you don't
if you only have one and not the other
it gets you pretty far but eventually
yeah it all collapses under the weight
of its own hypocrisy or contradictions
the the Tiger Woods episode in the book
that's that's probably the example you
spend the most time on yeah most number
of pages on and I think it requires that
because there's so many chapters to that
to really understand it but you go into
it if I'm not mistaken it's in the
spirit section right yeah divide the
book up into basically like mind body
spirit right I think the spirit section
could also be entitled daddy issues yes
pretty much all these yeah well have
like huge issues with their dads mhm yes
sometimes it's a mommy issue but it's
mostly exactly mom and dad they screw us
up or something like you know it's like
they try but it's all their fault right
and there were certain aspects of Tigers
story that I I didn't know how like how
intense that was his dad oh yeah I think
I think and this was a different media
environment than we live in now but I
think we all sort of bought into this
myth that like Oh Tiger Woods just had
like one of those hard driving like show
parents and it's like Tiger Woods his
dad may have been a psychopath like like
its mutt like Tiger Woods his father was
deeply abusive was like Michael
Jackson's father level bad you know even
that we go like oh you know he was
Michael Jackson's dad was bad it's like
no Michael Jackson was like a horribly
abused victim of a monster sentian and
it produced this great champion but then
we all saw you know the wreckage
ultimately that was manifested by that
then we have fragile champ right and
then we have the great comeback also
mmm-hmm
and not in the galley it's fixed and
right yeah I noticed that because I have
the galley and I'm reading it and I was
like oh I wonder if he's gonna get to
2009 and you kind of mentioned mm I be
don't go go into detail on it so in the
final book there's more well I just I
like I captured the downfall and then it
was nice to see him winning that major
and like he the first thing he does is
hug his
the end of it yeah so you know it
actually in the galley it's a little bit
more depressing because it's like a
story with no redemption and I do like
that he redeemed himself so I like I
think it would it was missing a 5%
change that that it was able to Dowe I
mean that's it's great that he won I
think I think people are now willing to
gloss over just how dark and bad it was
which is you know mmm we do the same
thing with Steve Jobs ago he came back
from the getting fired from Apple it's
like yeah he was horrible he should have
been fired from Apple and probably it
was a probably on paper it was crazy to
bring him back
mm-hmm you know the Tiger Woods story is
very dark and yes very driven by daddy
issues yeah well from a very top level
the book really you know when you are
trying to drive the reader towards this
understanding of what it means to be
still and the importance of stillness
it's it strikes me as as really this
journey to learn to turn inward and and
really crowd out the externalities it's
the externalities that create the
confusion and the stress and the anxiety
and you know the competitive nature and
the measuring and all of those things
that prevent us from being clear on you
know what it is you know that is
ultimately driving us I think it's true
but I think maybe that's something that
Eastern philosophy people miss reading
if they go like okay like I gotta
eliminate noises I got a eliminate
distraction I gotta live a quieter life
blah blah blah
it's like Tiger Woods had like a monk
like obsession with golf but was so
broken spiritually that it wasn't like
noise in Tiger Woods's ear that was
making him unhappy it was the voice
inside of his head you know what I mean
and and so I think you can fix it's I
think I'm trying to say you've got to
attack it from all angles like if you
have mental discipline but then you know
you have this deep insecurity inside you
that's you know gonna never never feel
like you're enough in a way almost your
mental discipline is your worst and
because it's just gonna be you think
like oh I if I win a Super Bowl I will
be happy you know or dad will love me if
I become a billionaire and action of the
Michael Jordan example of that's famous
speech that he gave yeah yeah and then
also it's like you have those things but
you eat terribly and you don't take care
of yourself physically and you have bad
habits it all feeds it there's there's
no like one magical thing you do and you
have stillness it's this like process of
getting there right so if you're very
mentally sound and disciplined but you
don't take care of yourself physically
or you have like a pap you have all
kinds of crazy emotional problems
synergistically this is not gonna work
it might work yeah towards a short-term
goal yes as a life yes yes exactly and
all of these things yeah so it's like
yeah your concentration helps you become
a great artist but what's motivating you
to become a great artist it's the sense
that you know if you're famous now you
matter or that if you get accepted by
this cool crowd now you'll feel good
about yourself you know or but then it
begs the question of you know who are
who are you without those things right
like you talked about
Kenzo the archer and you know this idea
of like letting go of hitting the bull's
eye being detached like holding onto
things loosely and then trying to figure
out how you square that with well if I
want to be a champion like I've got to
be you know my my eyes of f2 have to be
on the prize like I've got to be driven
in some respect and it's this balance of
those two things
yeah Billie Jean King the tennis coach
she was saying is like so what makes you
a great athlete is your relentless
desire for improvement and never being
satisfied with the current state of your
performance the irony is that that is
obviously the attitude you need to
become the best but it is also
antithetical to enjoying your
right not only enjoying being the best
but to even acknowledge that you got to
the top and you are the best you know
what I mean right because you're like
you're focusing on how how much left you
have to do or how bad you feel after
that you're just never you're never
gonna feel good because you have this
quirk of your brain that makes you
always focus on what's wrong and you
know like it's when I wanted to be a
writer
like it would have been like oh I could
have a book that's making it and then
quickly your minds like oh well actually
like what if it was a best-seller what
if it sold a million comments or what if
you had a whole bunch of books or you
know what if you've won this award or
what if you know like the idea that even
one like if you told me that the
opposite the sre the outside of say
obstacle that one person in professional
sports would have read the book I would
have been like done that's success I'll
settle for that like I accept your offer
that's it but then you're like whoa why
hasn't sewn so red or you know like you
know and there's that other guy over
there that sold more books totally and
in a one hand that's good that can one
keep you humble like I once asked even
press fella said how what's it like to
sell a million books and he was like
it's like I mean he's like unbroken is
sold like 10 million copies and and and
I was like that is like a good attitude
because like it doesn't you're not like
sitting and look how awesome I am I know
some of those people were like they're
very quick to tell you how many copies
they sound as if it says something and
and so it keeps you humble it keeps you
hungry but at the same time how grateful
it also deprives you of being grateful
for what you've done
yeah and that gratitude and appreciation
you've earned so you're but you're
depriving yourself of it yeah
so the solution lies in falling in love
with process really I think so yeah I
mean you talk about the word is enough
it comes up in the book a lot it called
it were they were the e word that like
Tiger and his dad could never utter out
loud that that you know leaves him you
know incredibly unhappy as a human being
but
then you bring up the example of heller
who you know writes this amazing book
and then goes on to continue to write
books and kind of lets it go and is is
is happy with his circumstances and yet
still very productive yeah yeah so
joseph heller's at a party with Kurt
Vonnegut at the house of this
billionaire and Vonnegut's like sort of
needling him and he's like hey you know
you wrote catch-22 but you know this guy
made more money than you then you will
ever make in your life like at work this
week you know and and Heller goes but I
have something he'll never have and he
says what's that he says the the notion
that I have enough and I think we are
all deep down very scared that if we
ever say that word that's the moment we
become complacent and the guy behind us
passes us and in a way it is like if
you're running a race and you're like oh
this is fast enough like that's when you
get past so there is that element of it
but at the same time like so you're not
allowed to be happy with the fact that
you wrote one generational defining like
you know classic novel that helped
millions of people and defined you know
what that experience was for a whole you
know again a whole generation and and
like my favorite thing from Heller is
its reporter goes like you know you've
never written anything as good as as
catch-22 again and he says who has is
right so like he is sad it he there like
I'd like that that's just great like
yeah maybe I won't ever write a book as
good as you go or obstacle maybe they
won't sell as many copies like but it's
not gonna prevent me from continuing to
write I don't think you know I don't
want it to and I don't want I I what I
want to do is love the process like I
want to love sitting down starting the
next one right and part of what drives
the process is understanding that
there's a destination like it's it's
it's this tension between these two that
I think look these are the questions
that go back you know
yawns that we struggled with like
competitiveness versus letting go and
you talk about like you know the no mind
being totally present and in the moment
and how do you reconcile that with deep
thinking and how do you how do you
square being a very competitive person
with these ideas about letting go and
surrender and like you know I have my
own personal stories with this with you
know I've introduced to these ideas and
in in sobriety I'm like surrender like
yeah give up like like no I that's not
who I am at all I met when you really
can grok what that means and implement
those truths into your life you realize
that your life becomes much larger and
it flourishes and and and you don't have
to that fear of like well this is who I
am this story that I tell myself about
Who I am I'm driven by these what you
learn later are really character flaws
character defects that flame out quickly
and you know end up you know causing
more damage than good yeah and I think
the east and west sort of align on this
I think it's Confucius but so he you
know he tells one student to do you know
he's like you gotta like um you know
avoid your parents and then he tells
this other student like you gotta go
figure out how to love your parents or
something I forget what it is and this
other students like but you just told
them to do opposite things and he was
like one student needs X and the other
needs Y and I think what I like about
Eastern philosophy that I think Western
philosophy is less explicit about is
just as sort of like embracing or
tolerant toleration tolerance for
paradox and contradiction and absurdity
do you know what I mean like it's just
like like like these Zen koans yeah like
they're supposed to be confused I think
that's what they real I think
enlightenment is like oh this maybe it
doesn't really mean anything you know
like that I it's the it's the idea that
there is what one hand clapping is maybe
it's just like maybe what enlightenment
is just sitting with that a long time
and going like this is a trick question
right you know or something well with
stoicism there's an inherent
practicality applicability like you can
read that and you can immediately
implement these things
in your life and improve your quality of
life but the Eastern traditions are much
more ephemeral yeah right and and
perhaps that's you know where it gets
frustrating and and that's why it's not
as cool as stoicism because I think it's
demanding more of people yeah because
you you really have to you know reckon
with these things in a deeper way to
really get to to the point where you can
even understand what they're trying to
communicate to you yeah and and Kenzo
who's the archery instructor in the zen
and the art of archery I think he would
have these Western students and they
were like show me how to do this like I
want to get better at this and I think
part of the reason his his instructions
were so vague and contradictory and
weird was it was a overreaction to that
idea that like this is the five-step
process for becoming a master in archery
you know what I mean like and becoming a
master at anything really like basically
saying master yourself before you even
think about like what the arrow you know
where the arrow is gonna go like you
have to become somebody who knows how to
be present who knows how to you know
remove distractions from their lives who
knows how to focus deeply like all of
these things are things that you have to
devote your entire you know years and
years and years to get good at and
that's that I think you know a big part
of it is just like surrendering to
whatever the master is telling you and
that's the hardest thing like we it's
like the student it's almost like Eric
like when the students like teacher
teach me this you know and I think with
the that sort of Zen Buddhist sort of
archetype is like you don't tell me what
to do I tell you what to do you know
what I'm like yeah like it's I think and
and that's where that higher power idea
comes into it's like oh wait like you're
not in charge like fundamentally
accepting that you're not driving the
process the process is driving the
process yeah you have to submit to that
and I think it's not I don't sit down
and go it I'm gonna I'm gonna grab a
book here out of from brute strength
it's like no I'm gonna open myself up
and I'm gonna follow the steps
and it's going to ensue if I'm patient
enough and accepting enough and
vulnerable enough yeah to have an open
mind to be teachable to to be able to
get into that you know Fred Rogers
childlike state where you're able to
hear something that might be at odds
with the way that you see the world yeah
yeah sure you know I think the idea of
it was interesting that you brought
12-step into it you did I get that right
by the way you did yeah I mean it's it's
tricky to communicate what that's all
about and it took me a really long time
to really understand what that was about
but I think you're very accurate in the
sense that a lot of people are reticent
to go into that community because of
their hang-ups around you know the word
God and what it means to you know accept
that there's a higher power and and
truthfully there is no religious strain
in it whatsoever it's just asking you to
believe that something is greater than
yourself
yeah and addicts by their nature are
control freaks and they you know have
strong opinions about how they see the
world and a lot of them are emotionally
damaged and have hang-ups around the
church etc but all all it's saying like
you could be the most anti religious
person of all time but what I always say
to people who are struggling with that
is like listen you're you for the life
of you you can't stop drinking dude so
clearly you can't control that and you
go into this group and there's all these
people here who figured out how to do it
and they've been doing it for a little
while like maybe they know something you
don't like they're your higher power
yeah they can be you had to sit look at
them and say this group consciousness
has more strength than I do yeah and I
think I just think it's so it's such an
epitome of the Attic mind and of our
mind as a it's like it's like okay so
you enroll in the you enlist in the army
and the drill sergeants like you know
shave your head and make your bed and
blah blah and you're like what none of
these things matter you're like giving
them your opinion like this is a like a
300 year old institution that's created
the greatest fighting force and they
history of mankind that's done all these
things and you this person who's thought
about it for like 8 secconds who has
never done anything in their life is
convinced that you know better right and
I think it's it's like it's mo a huge
part of it is just like it's almost the
fact that it's a hard thing to do is
what makes it so powerful and it's like
it's like that's the initiation into the
fraternity like are you willing to do
what we say do you I think there's a
part I think that works yeah it requires
humility I mean the analogy and 12-step
would be you walk in and they're like go
make coffee sweep the floor like you
know here you have a commitment you say
hi to every person that walks in the
room and you're like what does this have
to do with not drinking anymore yeah
it's like don't ask questions just do it
and and I struggle with that for a long
time and when I finally I was so broken
that I just let go of all of that and I
just said tell me what to do and I'll do
it yeah my life changed yes cuz I think
a big part of that is just being
malleable and teachable yes no I think
that's - and I think and it's it's the
willingness to ask for help and also
perhaps even more powerfully the
willingness to accept oh and look I'm
still an atheist I don't I can't get my
eye deep my head around the idea that
there is a God particularly like a
Christian God like I had just have
trouble with it but at the same time
what I struggle with what at least keeps
my mind open and then what sort of
inspired this chapter is this like but
basically every person that I that I
admire that's ever lived for almost all
of human history they were able to wrap
their head around this like why am I
better than them why am i smarter than
them I don't I can't that can't be right
do you know what I mean so where does
that leave you it leaves me with at
least at least the like it definitely
makes me go from atheist to agnostic
right which i think is a big step right
cuz it atheist says like I know there's
not a god agnostic says I don't [ __ ]
know
you know what I mean so I think it at
least gets me there and then there are
moments where I can go like this is just
all incomprehensible
there must be something do you know what
I mean
and so it's gotten me closer to the idea
of there being a higher power or at
least the idea that like Italy I'm very
comfortable going like I'm not in charge
and I'm not choosing really any of this
yeah and so how do you think about that
with respect to stillness like
somebody's connection to their form of
faith and I mean I don't I just I find
it it doesn't strike me as a coincidence
that this stillest people are all the
ones and not religious in the
fundamentalist sense those are probably
the most miserable people and they're
probably compensating for the intense
doubt and self-loathing that they
actually feel but a you know the the the
the people who undergo that you know the
Jesus on the cross in this horrible pain
asking for forgiveness for the people
who inflict it on I mean that's just
like incredible to wrap your head around
you know or just just the you know the
the sort of the the prayer that the
person falling to their knees and
praying when the world is you know the
weight of the world is on their shoulder
I just find that to be so beautiful and
inspiring and it's like how do i how do
I get there and then going you know even
back back to the idea of the gods just
this idea that like oh man there are
these things happening that that are
beyond us and that that you're we are
not the central driving forces of our
lives from the universe I can get there
pretty easily
the Stoics had this idea that that so
the logos which is actually means the
way in the Bible but it predates
Christianity you know Marcus really is
ideas that were like a dog tied to a
cart and so like the dog can fight
against the cart dog can lay down and be
dragged by the cart or the dog can run
alongside the cart cheerfully I can get
there yeah well the example from the
book that springs to mind is the
astronaut who looks at earth yeah when
they're when he's orbiting and and
extrapolating on that idea the more you
kind of look at you know the the
magnitude of the universe or the you
know when you drill down to the
subatomic particles like stuff gets
crazy like we our brains can't even yeah
begin to understand what's happening and
for me like that's where I can find a
healthy place of awe and wonder and yes
and that and that place of humility also
like we don't we don't maybe someday
we'll understand this but maybe not
maybe it's beyond our mental capacity to
fully grasp and rather than that making
me uncomfortable I actually find I find
comfort in that mm-hmm yeah I mean I was
I read this book a couple years ago I
was talking about like basically like
the history of like extreme weather and
it was saying that like we basically
didn't know what a tornado was until
like right around the time of the
founding of America because they don't
really have tornadoes that much in
Europe and some sort of an American
thing it's like a Midwest thing
basically but like so so there would be
these reports where it's like all of a
sudden like one side of a street was
destroyed and not the other side of the
street you know and in your sight what
and so when the world was so
inexplicable and we had so little
science it was much easier to go like oh
yeah God did this right like I could
imagine if you hear this terrible sound
and you you run and you hide and then
you come back and it looks like God just
destroyed it smote smited down the
sinners or what I was like so and this
you know you go back further to the the
the Greek or ancient idea of the gods
like when the universe was much harder
to explain it was easier to get there
and so in a way it almost it's almost a
greater challenge but a more meaningful
challenge to seek out that aw and to
look at it and so I mean talking about
going to space if you seem like the blue
marble photo like it's that famous
iconic photo of Earth from space it's
like that photo was taken it like 1971
like we that's that's at 50 years ago
for the first time we saw Earth from not
earth uh-huh and so when I think about
that I go it wow that's like that gives
me a little bit of that humility and awe
you know to look at that photo and but
it's so fleeting yeah you think like
that is such a
magnificent thing that should just
permanently alter our perception of who
we are and our importance and all of
that but it evaporates almost
immediately and we're back to our phones
in our daily lives and you know the the
the example that beautifully illustrated
that in the book is is Abramovich is art
installation at moment we're like 79
days straight she stares at people all
day long like walking us through that so
everyone should watch the documentary
the artist is present it's incredible I
think it's on Netflix but basically so
she's doing this retrospective at MoMA
of her entire career and she's a famous
you know creative but provocative
performance artist and that the exhibit
is called the artist is present and
because that's what she is she's
president her work so she comes up with
the idea of like I'm gonna be present
for every day of the exhibition and she
gets a table not like this and they sit
there and a line of people one after
another it gets like five minutes to
just sit across from her and she just
sits there and stares at them in the
face she doesn't go to the bathroom she
doesn't get up she thinks she goes to
she goes home every night but like like
an eight-hour shift basically an
eight-hour shift in Mobile in a chair
and the only thing she gets is between
people she looks down gathers herself
and then looks up she could hear the
bathroom know for eight hours should
head out and she doesn't eat or do
anything it's like inhuman but it like
so they asked her collaborator it's like
her ex-husband but her former artistic
partner and they like describe to him
what she's gonna do and go what do you
think because I have no thoughts only
respect which is that kind of like what
I think of your your your Iron Man of
Iron Man's do you know any mean like I
don't it's like so incomprehensibly
impressive that it's you're just like
wow okay you know what I mean like
you're just like wow you're like a human
did that well I think with her like when
I read that in the book like no I have
no thoughts just respect I was also
thinking like she has no thoughts either
retinal response
like that for that problem shows up and
sits across from another human being and
is fully 100% present for that
experience and and and and there's
nothing more respectful that you can do
for another human being than to give
them your undivided attention and the
crazy thing is that like even though
she's not saying anything even though
none of that is like in the description
like everyone immediately feels like in
the documentary you can watch people
dude sit down and they would just start
weeping because they'd never experienced
that I mean maybe I have but you know
what I mean like I've never just it's
probably what people and I'm not
comparing her but that's probably what
people felt being near Jesus or it's one
of the when one of these prophets and
look sometimes they're mentally ill
that's what I'm getting at hugging Alma
do you know about Amma hugging Saints no
she's this woman and like this you know
enlightened you know higher
consciousness and she travels the world
and wherever she goes thousands of
people show up and wait in line just to
you know sure and she gives everybody a
hug I've had that experience too and
it's like whether she's enlightened or
not is neither here nor there it's just
somebody who is so present for that kind
of experience as a rare yes thing yeah
and then we know that and yet we live
our lives the exact opposite of that
right and so I feel like her the
artistic installation is this twofold
thing like one to provide people with
that a glimpse of what that can be like
that experience but also to underscore
and illustrate the ephemerality of the
whole thing because everyone just
immediately goes back to you know they
just it lapses immediately or all the
bad behavior that gets manifested in
people jockeying for position in line
and well this one woman she you she gets
up there and she takes her dress off and
it was clearly she was she decided not
to wear underwear so that it's like she
planned out like so you can trap Marina
is completely present and meanwhile this
woman spent we
planning and executing a stunt and who
knows what her intention was I don't
think she was like I just want attention
but it was like she was the opposite of
morena you know what I mean and that she
was calculating and thinking about the
react like and that's to me who we what
we are right and and so that's but I
think that's the real statement yes in
the art instil in in her performance
right is to is to demonstrate that this
is this is what we do as human beings
yes and that even at what does it say
that presence for five minutes is a
life-changing
it's like a ride at Disneyland do you
know what I mean it's it's like
everyone's got to go on Splash Mountain
one time everyone's got to go see Mount
Rushmore everyone's got to see the Mona
Lisa it's not even though any of us
could get it ourselves at any moment
right we want to pay to see it at a
museum and then wait in line and then
and try to distract the person and throw
them off like our art goal is to like
you know just ruin it yes try it yeah
yeah well it's like I wanted to you know
scribble on the Mona Lisa instead of
just take it in right where I got to
take up this is a little like smart I
think this is 2010 so it's fine you see
people in the audience using flip phones
you know which I know it is the
smartphone is definitely invented but
they had not consumed snow roll selfie
culture hadn't completely yeah I don't
know if Instagram might not have existed
yet but the point is like it wasn't
quite like hey let me show you that I
did this but a lot of people were there
clearly to just get it off their bucket
list yeah so her being this you know
pillar of presence somebody who's able
to root themselves in the now and this
experience of no-mind let's let's you
know but that up against the importance
or value of deep thinking okay those two
things kind of contradict but also can
live complimentary well so I was talking
I was actually talking to I don't I
don't think it's a problem that's why I
was talking to Sean McVeigh this morning
it's the coach of the Rams and it was so
on the one hand you want to be present
you want to go with the flow you want to
do you wouldn't do all that stuff and
then he was upset about something that
he'd seen it practice right and I
watched him sit there in his office work
himself out of acting on that anger do
you know what I mean like he was like I
didn't like how we practice today I am
gonna like I'm disappointed in the team
were better than this I'm but instead of
he actually he canceled yeah I think I
can say this he cancelled the team
meeting that they were about to have
because he didn't want to go in there
and unload on everyone uh-huh because it
would have made him feel better but it
wouldn't have solved the problem right
and he didn't he couldn't yet he didn't
have a handle on what had caused the
problem and what the solution was yet
and so it's this balance of like yeah
it's be where your feet are go with the
flow let go you know
don't suppress your emotions and yet
also objectively we know a large portion
of our emotions are harmful and
destructive and you know short-term and
and what you need is the ability to like
zoom out see yourself from a distance
extrapolate out into the future and go
what will happen if I do X like Kennedy
in the Cuban Missile Crisis is totally
present and yet at the same time working
out the decision tree of if I do X they
will do Y and then I will be do this and
where will that lead us yeah so it
that's what I mean where it's like
that's not a contradiction that's just
[ __ ] life you know life is
complicated and sometimes the situation
calls for a and sometimes it calls for
the opposite of a yeah I mean the master
in that situation would be detached
emotionally from what was transpiring in
front of him and would be present enough
to have clarity on what the next best
decision or action would be to take and
would be able to fluidly implement that
in the moment and would not have
canceled the meeting because that person
would have been able to comport them
selves and communicate in a way where it
could you know culminate in a productive
result
yeah although I wouldn't I don't know if
I'd say like that she's somehow short of
mastery I think it's more he's like I
know where I am right now and I know
where I'm going to end up after I work
through this so I'm gonna give like so
Kennedy in the Cuban Missile Crisis he
has this expression is this I want to
use time as a tool not as a couch and
what he means by that is like I'm not
gonna sit back and just do nothing I'm
gonna I'm gonna give myself time and
space so I can use it and I what what
Shawn was doing is going if I react now
it will be out of anger or frustration
but if I can think through this and come
to a solution I can not only solve this
problem but I can also model to my
players like the importance of not being
ripped around by your passion he's like
how can i how can I get mad at a player
who objected to a bad call from a ref
gets a flag and sends us back ten yards
and then turn around and around yeah
that in practice the distinction that I
see in that is he had the self-awareness
to realize that he was not going to be
responding productively but that he was
going to be reacting emotionally yes and
that self-awareness was such that he was
able to put the brakes yeah on his
original plan and not make that mistake
yes I guess what I'm saying is the
master wouldn't have even had to go
through that calculus because they would
be in a place of yes they would have the
capacity to respond and I think the
distinction with JFK is he needed to buy
that time for himself but he also
realized it would be productive for
Khrushchev because he knew that
Khrushchev over to over time would come
to a healthier realization about what
the next best thing would be well and so
two things actually that was something I
talked to Shawn about it was like you're
one of the things he was frustrated with
was how the players had stepped up but
that none of the players had stepped up
in practice and solve the situation and
that he didn't feel like it was he
didn't want to be the coach that fixes
everything this is what you want a great
leader on the field to do
and so the idea that he would jump all
over them and tell them exactly what the
problem was and not give them time to
fix it themselves themselves was
actually only compounding the exact
problem he was hoping yeah I guess you
don't know it's like it's like my
problem is nobody stepped up on the
field in the moment and was like the
leader and said come on guys let's do
this
right and he's like but what if what if
they do in the hall on the way to
breakfast this morning
it's not as fast as I want but it's you
know what I mean yeah I get it
and so I think that's really important
and yeah that is what Kennedy was doing
the Missile Crisis she's like I don't
think Khrushchev thought this all the
way through if I give him some space
he'll come to his senses I'm not gonna
let him walk all over me but I'll let
him figure this out and I'm not gonna
make it worse I'm not gonna back him I'm
not gonna put him in a position where he
can't do that mm-hmm and and I would
guess someone like I mean Shauna's only
been a head coach for a few years he's
already one of the most sort of
ascendant promising coaches of an entire
generation I mean he's my age and he
coached a team in the Super Bowl it's
incredible yeah but I would yeah I would
imagine him in 15 or 20 years when he's
been when he's seen this 15 times that's
when you become the master and you go
exactly what you said yours like so into
it if you can't even explain how you
knew exactly what to do in that moment
and and yeah it's probably a thing you
get so when you're you're there and
you're observing this do you say
something like are you just watching
it's both I mean on the one hand like
I'm just a student of all these things
so I love just being a fly on the wall
and I'm learning and I love seeing it's
easy for me to talk about these things
philosophy it's even easy for me to read
a bunch of books on the Cuban Missile
Crisis but I'm never gonna be in the
Situation Room and that's happening yeah
so I'm always one of the reasons I say
yes to speaking things or I even you
know I have my company that works with
authors and brands is that like it's
putting me in a position to just see
stuff that I can then translate into my
writing and then you know people ask for
my advice and and I offer it I don't
know how helpful it is but you know I I
just love to me like I learn a lot when
I go like I'm talking to them about
stuff which is stuff I know
about but I really am there to see stuff
I don't know about yeah I'm still trying
to wrap my head around this distinction
between presence and thought in the
sense that we have Eastern traditions
that talk about you know this idea of no
mind like focus on the breath like the
idea is to you know really try to
broaden those moments where your
consciousness is not invaded by
narrative yeah right and that provides
the space and the calmness and the
stillness for inspiration for correct
action for all of these things versus
what would be more of a the in the in
the tradition of the cohens like yeah
let's grapple with these you know the
the mental gymnastics of a very
difficult problem to train our brains to
learn how to take these right actions
yeah I don't know I mean there's just
one sort of stoic he's almost more of a
senator he's a sort of stoic seems Risto
and he's this early stoic he's sort of a
contrarian and he was like the wise man
doesn't think simply pops into his head
what the right thing to do is and that
sounds like a very Eastern thing I just
I just don't know if that's true and and
and I know from my experience that maybe
it's it's a mix of both right it's like
I'm thinking very deeply about a writing
problem that I have for cracking the
code on this Kennedy chapter or any of
the chapters in the book and then I'm
working on it and I make some progress
like I get words down I get in an order
and then I go for a run or a swim later
in the afternoon and then the real
solution pops in my head I don't know if
you can have one without the other I
think it is both I think it is both like
Kennedy has to game theory every
possible outcome and do these decision
trees to figure out like what the you
know what could possibly happen with
anything that he does but fundamentally
also these decisions need to be a
function of of a well-honed intuition
and
that's really developed through being
able to be present with yourself and he
goes swimming during the Cuban Missile
Crisis he writes a letter swimming it
something's a big thing with a lot of
people I think so I think so he's
obsessed with water I mean he's a guy
that grew up on the water you know
uh-huh
but he writes a letter to the gardener
from the White House like thanking her
because she held the Rose Garden was a
big yeah yeah and and I think look it's
like mr. Rogers went swimming which I
did not know oh it's beautiful it's
beautiful I want to go to the Pittsburgh
Athletic Club where he swam I just
wanted to be in that space but he and
have you seen the previews for the Tom
Hanks I saw the trailer yes he swims in
it yeah but you know I think from
reading Eastern philosophy and maybe
look there's parts that are missing from
stoicism that maybe they explain in
length and other text that were lost but
it's like you almost get the sense from
like Buddha or something it's like oh so
you're telling me I can solve like
complex math theorems by just like
sitting there and it pops into my head
like that's not that's not true
but and I know you had kaolin I think
it's it's like it's the it's both it's
like working very intensely eliminating
distraction it's doing the work and then
the solution pops in your head in the
shower yeah you know like I think you
need both how have you taken what you've
learned from the process of writing this
book like how have you made changes in
your own life like what is it that
you're struggling with the most where
this has been helpful so like today was
a good example and I didn't do a good
job but it's like I had to park at this
and another podcast had thing in the
morning and then I had to drive here
from Orange County and I had to check in
to my air B&B in time and I have this
email that has to go out and I need my
wife to like proof it and then I wanted
to get a run in and like all of a sudden
I'm like I'm like stressed out of my I
got it like all these things and they
all have to go right in the right order
and I was like writing in my journals
like you know I don't I don't want to
feel flustered
today and I don't want to be short with
people because none of this matters do
you know what I mean like net like even
like for it was hard for me to text you
to say like hey could I come 30 minutes
later
and because like I my instinct is like
always white-knuckle this do you know
what I mean yeah I'm like I got that and
I was like guess no but I might think
it's like I'll just squeeze it all in
I'll just [ __ ] squeeze it all in and
and so part that's part of letting go to
it's like like this is all an illusion
in my mind like this the pressure is
actually saying like I even scheduled
like I picked this it's not even like
I'm not even like some actor or where
it's like the publicist put me on this
tour felt like but just realizing how
much of the pressure I put on myself and
how many times I force myself into
situations that are gonna make the end
state that I want very unlikely so
that's been a big one
you know eliminating that amount of time
I spent on devices eliminating the the
inputs that really make me unhappy has
been a you know or the that challenge my
stillness has been a big one having kids
has probably been the primary you'd I
guess my thinking would have been like
having kids will be chaotic and
stressful and difficult and so I'll have
less it's actually been the exact
opposite because there's such a good
reminder of like what you could actually
be anytime if you choose to be yeah and
what's really important I mean you talk
about relationships in the book and any
hard driving type a personality is prone
to you know fantasies of what their life
would be like if all if every all people
went away yeah I could just do what we
do and there'd be no obstacles yes or
anybody else vying for our attention or
our time and you know that's one of the
great illusions I think and as messy and
as difficult and time-consuming as
relationships are you know you pointed
out very point-blank in the book like
yeah but then there's no value and
anything that you're doing yeah yeah
like there's this quote from Philip Roth
that I found this he'd been married for
a long time apparently was like a
horrible marriage because a woman wrote
like this nasty memoir about it but he
was saying he was like now that I'm
single he's like all I think all I have
to focus on is my work he's like it's
like there's always an emergency and I'm
the
or something like that and I was like
that sounds horrible
like the fact like what my life would be
if I was a hundred percent in charge of
it and it was all about me would be so I
sometimes you think that's the fantasy
like oh that guy single he goes where he
wants he does whatever he wants you know
and then you realize like fantasies is
actually a [ __ ] nightmare you know
especially when you go through difficult
stuff might be nice you know on a
Tuesday beautiful you do whatever you
want you go for a two-hour run instead
of going like I got to be back here in
45 minutes or whatever but but what
about when you get a cancer diagnosis or
what if you when you find out you're I
don't know you're booked out rejected or
you know like like the relationships are
there for the hard times and also if
you're in the right relationships with
the right people these things float your
boat I mean yeah this is like an
accelerator to everything that you
imagine for your life well I've been
saying that too like I think the
generation before maybe the couple
generations before you know that that
experience so much pressure to have kids
like you have to have kids at the heaven
by this time you know woman shops to
have kids did a really good job making
it clear that like having kids is hard
and that you can't really have it all
there's a lot of sacrifices and and it
takes a lot out of you and all this
stuff and I think in the process kind of
under played like what you get in the
trade mm-hmm do you know what I mean and
that like it's like like um who was it
there's some author and he was talking
about how is a great writer like a very
famous writer and he was saying that
someone came up to him and said don't
have kids every kid you have is it book
you'll never write and he was like that
haunted me and he's like now Here I am
like writing this you know I'm looking
at my like three sons I'm like I think
that trade any day the wheel like what
none of these books matter you know like
at the end of the day none of these
books matter
none of the work we do matters really
like I'm it matters but it doesn't
matter and the idea that like you're not
gonna have kids or you don't have time
to get married or be in a serious
relationship with someone because like
the startup you're making is so
important it's just it's just laughable
if you look at it with any kind of
distance the the kind of flip reaction
to that though is oh well it's easy for
you to say because you're successful
right I mean in the sense that oh you
can say that you know this six like this
success isn't you know isn't all it's
cracked up to be because you're secure
sure now in your trajectory and I think
there's a delusion that we may
intellectually understand that and yet
we feel like it doesn't apply to us sure
although like when I think about it I go
like I should have had kids earlier like
III don't go like now missus goes back
to my theory that you were born out of
time ya know I just I just think I I get
that and look like I also have help you
know like people like how do you balance
at all it's like I pay someone to help
watch my kids you know what I mean like
that's and my wife doesn't have to go to
an office every day because we have our
own business you know like I'm not
saying that what I'm saying is that I
get what they're saying they're go it's
easy for you to say you have at the same
time because I have it I can tell you
that you know you think that writing a
best-selling book or having a lot of
money will make you feel good and that
you'll feel whole and that's the big lie
that we'd all go in and it's like at the
only moments where I really feel good
like my walk in the morning with my son
that's um that's what wholeness feels
like you know hearing my my book hit
number one it feels nice for like eight
seconds but it it it that's a biological
adaptation mm-hmm where we go hey if we
if we cross that ocean
if we kill those people and take what's
theirs then we'll be happy you know then
I'll feel good about myself unabated
craving yes that compels us and to go to
the daddy issues I think that like it's
I think for me it was like oh like if I
really get successful and it's this is
where my daddy issues it but it's like
if I'm objectively successful and what I
do is very impressive then my parents
will right give me what they should have
given me at birth
how do you know and how's that going
it's a constant struggle you know but
but I mean one of the night one of the
nice parts of getting the stuff it's
nice that I got it hmm but the blessing
and the curse of it is you go nope still
doesn't do it yeah you know it's like
and then it was nice for what I
basically it was freeing to go like all
right and maybe some and some people
don't get this gift but it's going like
all right this doesn't impress these
people nothing will and I can stop truck
I can stop doing these things leave it
that there's a relief from that yeah
well one of the tools that you talked
about in the book for for navigating
this which I love is this idea of like
holding on loosely yeah right like not
not you know if you're like a
hard-charging person and you've got
these goals and you're just like make
this happen and you're just full of self
well chances are like there's gonna be
problems yeah you and the people who can
kind of release their grasp on it hold
it a little bit you know less tight be
open to you know dips and turns along
the way are the people who ultimately
end up in a better place yeah it's like
you go to a driving range one time and
you get this proven to you pretty
quickly it's like the harder you try to
hit a golf ball not only the less far
does it go
but like the worse the shot yes and the
idea that that's not true in life which
is much harder than golf mmm is
ridiculous yeah I was just in Montana a
couple days ago for this event it was
like this gathering of
cool athletes and people were there and
I had an opportunity to do a live
podcast with this woman Gwen Jorgensen
who won the Olympic gold medal in
triathlon in the last Olympics and was
dominant in her sport for a long time
and now she's making the transition to
marathon running which is super ballsy
yeah it's a great story but what this
holding on loosely thing reminded me or
just made me think about this
conversation was that she started out as
a swimmer she swam at the University of
Wisconsin and she kind of rode the bench
like she wasn't that great and she was
laced to swish she was not why so cold
well you're indoors use from an owner
but just the prot like it's like I'd
rather swim in a warm place yeah just
the waking up early going out in the
cold like better be a swimmer place
where it doesn't snow is what oh I'm
with you yeah but you know she grew up
as a kid like holding on very tightly to
this idea that she wanted to be an elite
yeah an Olympic swimmer and wrote her
gold times on her ceiling and like the
whole deal right and meanwhile like
every once in a while she'd go out and
run and she was this like incredibly
gifted runner yeah and to the point
where people were like hey you should
really think about like a running track
like no I'm a swimmer like she held on
so tightly to this idea this identity
that she had crafted about who she was
that she couldn't see this other
potential Avenue for herself and I think
it's short circuited her I mean
eventually it was inevitable she's yeah
she like made the switch to track and
she couldn't even qualify for instant
ways in swimming and like within a year
you know like being brand-new to this
sport she immediately is like you know
she's like Big Ten Champion and like the
rest is history but I wonder like had
she held a little bit more of loosely
yeah perhaps she would have realized
that much sooner he's in that Lance
Armstrong story - he was a triathlete
and then it was like oh yours way better
at biking than the other things like and
I think it's very I mean I love David
Epstein spoke on rain right where you're
like oh it's the problem is that they
told Tiger Woods he was a golfer and
that all of his identity was in being a
golfer paul graham has this amazing
essay called keep your identity small so
it's like
if you see yourself as a Republican it's
hard for you to change your mind when
you it's hard for you to see an issue
objectively because you're looking at it
from the lens of my identity as a
Republican and you don't want it you
don't want even though you actually
think X that contradicts your identity
as a Republican so you think about it
differently he said something like the
more labels you put on yourself the
stupid the stupider you are because now
all of a sudden you've limited what your
options are constructed this sense of
who you are yes story that you tell yeah
and and and so it I think this ties in
to the inner child thing too where it's
like so if your thing is like I gotta
impress mom and dad and what are the
things that impress mom and dad you're
already you've already closed yourself
off to all like maybe mom dad don't mom
and dad respect doctors but like you're
actually put here to be a guitar player
yeah and so how many amazing talents get
squandered because you know your mom and
dad are gonna find a way if your mom and
dad have made you being a doctor part
and parcel of them loving you they're
gonna find a way to not love you even
when you're the world's best doctor you
know what I mean like they're gonna
they're gonna go like oh you work here
or you know or they're gonna be like
that's like a neil strauss tweet yeah
but I think it's true do you know what I
mean like if you if you they're just in
the way that we move the goalposts on
ourselves so right because that's what
we do have you found what's the biggest
like if you changed course on any
long-held ideas that you've had like
have you had changes of heart or like
wow I always thought this was this way
and as a result of all this work and
research and deep thinking that I've
done on these subjects I'm changing my
mind on this I mean I do like changing
my mind I don't know if I have like some
like great example or like I switched
from you know this to that but yeah I
don't I don't know if I have one but I
think that is a good a great question is
like where where do you change your mind
have you changed your mind recently I
think a big one for me is just like
going like I need to like not care less
but like I have
wrapped a chunk of my identity up around
life knowing a lot about a lot of things
and having interesting opinions about
them I'm like trying to get more
comfortable with me like I don't I've
never heard of that but yeah I don't
know what's happening there right sure
you're right you know like like just
like instead of being the guy who always
is like oh yeah I read a book about that
yeah yeah or just like like oh let me
tell you why you're wrong about this
like it's like can I can I like Marcus
really you know it's possible to not
have an opinion about things like like
you do does not have an if that is
possible yeah it feels natural well
we're in this you know back to the
current culture like we've you know
calcified our ability to be nimble with
ideas and you know we're expected to toe
a certain line and have an opinion on
everything and I think it entrenches
these narratives and it's splitting us
apart and it's it's a roading the fabric
of our culture and our our ability to
have productive conversations yes ya
know the radicalization of one side
radicalizes the other side and then it's
just and there's there's there's you
know there's a lot of energy behind
preventing you from changing your mind
on anything yeah it's the risk of
stepping outside of whatever doctrine
you know you're sort of associated with
is become suddenly very hot right so
it's like what they're trying to do is
take away your ability to think about
this and trying to to sort of put
blinders on you and ratchet up the
stakes artificially and make it
impossible for us to like come to any
kind of compromise or solution or you
know what I mean there's like you can't
you can't have an opinion about this you
can only have this party line and and to
adopt a contrary opinion is to face
Oscars ostracization yes you know sure
a it goes to you talked about this in
the book to like the information diet
right I realize like fit not thick not
Han has spoken about yeah I think he was
actually probably more talking about
what you talked about that I think he
was I think if I remember that quote
correctly he's talking mostly about food
but you know it's like look if you're
putting like poison
you basically industrial agriculture in
your body yeah
garbage is going to come out but like
literally and figuratively but I think
it's it's just as true for information
if you are mainlining the constant
chattering of of manipulative you know
people who profit from your rage the
idea that like peace and stillness and
clarity and compassion goodness is going
to come out of that it's delusional
yeah the opportunity cost I mean the
this willingness that you have to have
to not be fully informed all the time
like there's this compulsion that so
many of us have that we need to be
up-to-date on everything all the time
and have an opinion so that if we meet
somebody we can say the right thing or
whatever and the truth is the
opportunity cost of that is that you
deprive yourself of that ability to
think deeply about what's most important
and you have to be willing to be like no
I hadn't heard about that or you know
about that all right I didn't see that I
didn't watch the debate I didn't see the
latest movie or whatever it is yeah yeah
yeah and and it's it's that's that that
feels like it like you're being it's
like a dereliction of duty but it's like
actually your duty is to go read a
history book and understand where this
all fits in you know what I mean your
duty is not to follow trivia in real
time like and also there's a humility
I've started saying this it's like smart
people are on that like like we have our
people on that you know what I mean they
don't necessarily don't you don't need
to have an opinion and voice your
opinion on everything on Twitter yes yes
like I think the the match the two mass
shootings that happened I mean this
won't go later but like to mass
shootings it's like no they don't need
me to condemn this it's objectively
wrong like you know what I mean like it
that's do you feel that pull though as
somebody with an audience like when
something like that happens
I and I open up Twitter and I look at
what's going on I feel like do I need to
say something and I'm like I don't I
think the ego is in the like my art like
I I'm gonna move the needle on this one
like like look if you're if you're you
know because you you have to square that
with like silence is you know if you're
silent about things that are wrong in
our culture like you're complicit right
but it's like I'm not silent talking to
I'm not talking to my two-year-old about
it but I'm not gonna if I had a teenager
I wouldn't be silent about it do you
know what I mean I would I would not be
silent about it where I have like real
impact where I so it's an interesting
thing because all rights I feel like my
job is to write is to apply sort of
ancient wisdom and history to modern
life so I'll write something I wrote an
email on Monday for daily stoic or just
like this email goes out to people and
and and I wrote a thing about Marcus
Aurelius in and & senic over both to
real world politicians who dealt with
like actual tyrants and murderous
dictators right and and so they were
talking about you know what it's like to
actually be these people you know like
Seneca was in Nero's Court like worse
than Donald Trump by a factor of a
hundred right and he's talking about you
know like what these people are like and
what it's like to be them and so I was
writing the thing about how like nobody
like people like what should I tell my
children about Donald Trump and they
think it's like you know these lessons
about the specific policies when it
really should be about like I should be
like kid this is what it's like to be a
horrible person this but you know what
this is what it does to you and
character matters and that you don't
need to talk to them about the fact that
he was you know he said you should grab
women by the [ __ ] I mean you you do in
that you teach your kids like what
boundaries are and what respect is but
it's more like you don't need to talk to
him about the word choice of [ __ ] you
need to talk to them about character
right and so I send out this email I
think it's very well reason it's
deliberately nonpartisan I'm a
center-right person but then I watch all
the people unsubscribe you
and my point they always send me why did
you do this I love you you know I loved
your writing you shouldn't be partisan
and like what I say is like my job is to
say what I think and what's important
and what I think the facts support in
the context with which I do my work and
what I don't do is think about what the
financial repercussions for doing that
are does that make sense yeah it goes
back I mean it's a predominant theme in
your book which is basically learning
how to hone your instincts and your
intuition and through that process
matched with deep thought to you know
Express a cogent informed opinion that
is liberated from the external
ramifications of you know putting that
out into the world yeah you like Marx
rila Sciences just do the right thing
the rest doesn't matter and so it's like
I thought that was the right thing to
write creatively you know politically
philosophically and so if if you know
500 people who I worked very hard to
bring into the universe left because of
that like whatever right because life is
way too short to live to not say what I
think to keep people whose opinions I
don't respect you know following my work
and life is also too short to be upset
by that or you know what I mean and so
you just you say what you say I don't
think it's correct I'm not saying it's
courage but it's it's like your
obligation as an artist is to speak
truth as you see it your art your it's
not to change the world you know your
your job is to speak truth whether that
truth ends up changing the world is one
thing but yeah it goes to this idea of
virtue of not being an abstraction but
in action mm-hmm absolutely
yeah it was interesting to read about
how Seneca became he became a victim of
you know basically being power-hungry
under Nero right like so he despite all
of his incredible wisdom he still
couldn't he still couldn't walk that
line of virtue to distance himself from
this terrible person and that's what I
say zone fortune was too
mostly tied to it yeah and and I think
yeah it's like he the Stoics over and
over virtues enough virtue is sufficient
what's right is doing the right thing
and here you have this guy making
compromises probably I mean and and I've
I've been there because I've worked for
people not nearly as bad as you know but
I've worked with people that you know
certainly in retrospect certainly
getting older but even at the time you
have ethical concerns about and you're
like but if I don't do this
what there's - there's the saver save
your conflicts I don't do this a worse
person it's gonna take my job take this
job and then you know like it so it's I
got to do this and then the other is
like but this is my shot ya know well
yeah when you're young - it's harder -
but I think like so I there's a couple
Republican senators who have read the
daily stoic and one of the weird even
weirder than the sports team is like a
couple times they've had me to the
Senate dining room to have breakfast and
like talk about philosophy which is just
like unreal they're not people are
having your own kind of like Seneca
experience why I wrote it I wrote a
newer time series about that cuz I
actually got offered a press secretary
position for one of the cabinet members
I know I'll send it to you and I
surprised myself by even thinking about
it I mean this is in early 2016 there's
a moment where it seemed a little less
crazy than it does now but anyways I was
so I'm there talking philosophy to these
guys and and you know they they they
pointed I was like why aren't people
stopping this you know like it seems so
obvious and and one of them said like
see that guy over there you know if he
hadn't said what he said about Trump
Trump probably would have named him like
I don't know head of the CIA or
something like that and so to them the
lesson was like you know by criticizing
you're depriving yourself of a position
to affect the change you've worked for
your whole life to think the principles
you honestly believe in or maybe just to
stop Trump from doing something stupid
right but to me too philosophical and I
think that's what sin
tells himself working for Nero if I'm
not Nero's tutor yeah who's he's not
gonna have one yeah if I'm not advising
him he'll do even worse things but the
problem is it's like to actually want to
be directed to the CIA for this
administration are you actually doing
like is that what you worked your whole
life to get and when you have that
position are you actually going to
follow your moral compass or is there
going to be another you know compromise
that's going to compel you to pull a
party line that's at odds with your true
nature yeah and so it's like so Seneca
writes all this stuff about philosophy
and then he ends up having to help
Nero justify why he tried to have his
mother assassinated you're just like
that's how quickly it escalated and
we're and rationalizing it and
rationalizing it and and yeah like I
don't I
and he only realizes too late what he's
got himself into and he tries he
basically what what this is and this is
where it's really insidious is Nero is
just piling money on top of Seneca like
Seneca becomes like the second richest
man in Rome and so obviously that was
interesting and fun and he talks about
it philosophically but you're just like
he he at some point senator those like
oh this is bad like what have I gotten
myself into I gotta get out of here
and he goes to Nero and he says I want
out and it's sort of like a blood in
blood out situation so yeah in mafia
yeah and then Seneca goes I'll give you
all the money back and Nero says no and
and he's like I'll let you partially
retire and and so Seneca gets that and
then Niro goes I don't like Seneca
anymore and he executes them basically
and so that Seneca realizes too little
too late that's probably what he's
writing some of these essays like the
essay that opens the book I think he
realizes he never comes out and says it
but I think he realizes that it was a
Faustian bargain and then he sold his
soul to the devil and classic Faustian
yeah like textbook yes
you know yes
and then we see this playing out in real
time yeah I mean like I had so much
respect for someone like general mattis
and it's so admirable that he resigned
on principle over we don't really know
what it was but he basically resigned up
a principal and it shocks Trump right
like but at the same time maybe the real
principal is like no you know I've how
many how how how much did the idea that
people like James masse we're going to
be in the administration allow other
people to rationalize voting for it and
supporting it not you know doing some of
the things we're doing now earlier right
so it's like it's one man's valiant
sacrifice is by another definition
complicity yeah yeah yeah super
interesting and these are timeless
ethical quandary right now I mean this
that's why it keeps it comes up time and
time again and what you know what is
ancient is is modern Aristotle is
Alexander the Great's philosophy
instructor do you know what I mean like
it would we tend to think that all these
things were clean but like it's so
complicated Confucius was it was not
just a philosopher he worked for these
princes and kings like these that that
studying the eastern stuff you realize
these people were much more of the world
than they seem and sometimes they did
horrible thing I mean Buddha had a wife
and child mm-hmm that he walked out on
yeah
which I found you know very hard to
square and and the issues with Leonardo
da Vinci his dad and like you know how
he's just trying to find these
benefactors it's like you just because
you don't think of him as a human being
yeah I did you really I really did yeah
anyways yeah well let's talk about the
body possession you you've pulled this
hat-trick again which you've done a
number of times which is essentially
you're kind of writing a self-help book
without writing a self-help book you
never kind of come out and give any
prescriptive advice I would say this
section is the most prescriptive of
anything you've ever written you're kind
of like look you should journal
like looking at these other you list
like 20 people in a row all these
amazing people like the journal everyday
like go on walks like you know take this
time like it yeah sleep like this is
very this is back to like practicality
yeah well it's because it's it's hard to
go like do this thing with your mind
because that's not how the mind works
but you can go like go for a walk here
the benefits of walking or you can say
like pure the costs of sleeping like I
can even though I wasn't there if you
the area Arianna Huffington tells a
story of like brushing their teeth in
the bathroom basically and passing out
and her cheek hitting the bathtub on the
way down and shat like I can hear that
noise she told that story on the podcast
it's yeah it's yeah it makes you so
uncomfortable do you know what I mean
and the solutions are so basic yeah go
sleep yes we go to sleep take a walk
here's one question I have yet you know
what I'm reading the the take a walk
section and you're naming all these
people I'm like where's David Sedaris
and then you bring him up in the hobby
section but I'm like I wanted you to go
deeper into his life garbage collection
thing because like that's like weird and
I think obsessive-compulsive on his Park
is like he can't miss a day and he's he
goes out and watch like 20 miles and he
picks up every piece of garbage in his
entire town he won like an award from I
know the Queen the Queen gave him like a
thing well I started doing it you did
yes yeah I were I live on I spent a lot
of time on the right our farms on this
dirt road and like my neighbors are
basically animals oppression says but I
was like you know they're just like oh
I'm finished with this someone throw it
out the window and it's not maintained
by the city so like are the county so if
I don't do it and it's I don't know like
it's actually wonderful like you can
look like a mattress the other day or
some type of mattress yeah but like my
son will now he's two-and-a-half you'll
point out garbage and say like pick it
up
uh-huh you know like so it to me it's
meaningful
and I'm already walking and I don't know
it's like instead of having a strong
opinion about whether restaurants
be allowed to have straws like why don't
we just pick up trash we see yeah you
know but it it I just love I put it in
the hobbies edge because it's a weird
hobby yeah yeah yeah but I but the
relationship between I thought about
this a lot like what is the relationship
between that practice and his creative
inspiration because there's something
about that you know low heart rate you
know kind of activity that creates space
for those little sparks I think it's
probably better for fiction and
nonfiction yeah although his stories are
sort of a mix of comes out like all day
but I just mean like I I think it's
about yeah slowing the mind down and
then these funny things are popping up
to you and then you go I think my
uneducated opinion is that maybe fiction
is a little bit more like you do a lot
of that and then you sit down and it
pours out whereas like to mean
nonfiction is it's a much more
construction of an argument so I think
it's more do you know what I'm saying
yeah I see what you're saying but I
don't know if that so I think this way
does it for six hours yeah I think
there's like a mental tweet share with
him I mean you could also you could have
also put that in the routine section
that's very much his routine and they're
yeah they're all related the writing is
part of my routine it's what I do before
I do XY and Z and and like again I think
going for a long walk might get you 70%
of what meditation gives you you know or
something like let's say it's the point
of my book is like okay met meditation
is great and let's say it's this it's
everything that we're told that it is
but for some reason we're not doing it
like a analogy you know meet Sethi is
that person is yeah he's like look
people don't keep budgets like you can
write a budget but you won't keep it so
I'm not going to tell you to do it but I
am gonna tell you to like set up these
Auto transfers in your bank account and
then it takes that out of it so my point
is like I could tell you to meditate and
I know I should meditate if I'm not
gonna I just knowing myself so like I
will take a walk and all on 80/20 it you
know I'll get a chunk of it the walk
takes a lot longer it does does and
you're willing to do that but not
meditate
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting right
yeah or sweat I mean to me swimming is
the yeah swimming that's the best one
there's something about swimming that's
like a pipe cleaner for your mind well I
think it's a murse my theory is totally
immersive so it has a sensory
deprivation component I think there's
something womb-like about swimming that
our bodies just respond to on a primal
level no screens you're looking down so
your that's all you're not really seeing
anything I think there's something about
cold like I've much I get much more out
of swimming in a cold pool than like
when it's not and then there's something
about the forcing yourself to do
something that at first you don't want
to do then there's you know then the
endorphin all mm-hmm I think and I just
think there's something magical about
water that like all all cultures seem to
have created fountains do you know any
mean like there's Roman fountains and
there's Buddhist fountains and there are
you know so yeah so you're drawing like
the calming effect of like seeing water
move but that's different from the
immersion like yeah I would agree with
you there's something that happens in
swimming that I don't explore kind of
you know agendas but there's something
distinct about swimming that's its own
unique thing like barton springs were
united so I'm an awesome where I like to
swim the most when I can like for like
500 years dating back at least basically
till we did that was a day like Indians
used to go there like we had like Native
Americans also saw it as a sacred place
do you know what I mean and would swim
in it and use it and be around it and so
it's like every culture has this strange
relationship with water some some
spiritual someone told me it's because
we're mostly water maybe that's it that
there's stuff you know what I need you
to put that in the in the spirit section
of the book yeah I'm the routines thing
one of the things that I liked is that
you know you know now we're in everybody
so no everybody's morning routine in the
whole you know it's like a if I just do
exactly what Stanley McChrystal does
then I'm gonna you know be this person
or whatever and and you don't really
kind of say it say it expressly but the
point is more just have one like yeah
you show all these people that all their
routines are wildly different but they
have a routine and they're disciplined
about it and you know what serves one
person is gonna be different from what
serves another and it's about you know
look if you could be still enough to
then figure out like what is gonna be
the one for you
and then adhere to that like you don't
need to get up at 4:30 and take a
picture of your wash like jakka well
like right if you do more power to you
but that's not for everybody yeah no I'm
actually it's like I think there's a
danger and some of those like sort of
books about our routines because people
think that it's like in the same way to
go Oh 10,000 hours okay just did one
hour just in another hour it's not that
it's it's like anything becomes sacred
if you treat it right and you do it
enough you know and and so it's not
about what other people's routines are
it's about yours and the thing I've
learned since having kids and you know
the fact that I have a pretty rigorous
travel schedule for my work is it's like
actually it's routines plural like I
have I have a travel routine I have the
day the kids got a day care routine the
day the weekend routine you know what I
mean and it and the ability to go like
today I'm switch him to this routine so
that like it's there's a there's also an
ego and then maybe this is why people
think they can't have relationships it's
going like this is what I do every day
you're getting in the way of the routine
I got a I got a stick with that thing
it's me the ability to go like sometimes
I do this sometimes I do this but it's
like when it's like if a then B if B
then C you know like having having
different routines I can sort of
effortlessly choose based on
circumstances not only it allows me to
be less rigid and less existentially
anxious if if the conditions are not
perfect yeah because we live in the
world and
that rigidity is gonna create all kinds
of anxiety and issues because life has a
way of intervening you know it's like
yeah no matter how well-intentioned you
are and how many boundaries you erect to
protect whatever routine you have like
stuff happens man and if you're gonna
freak out and your whole life is gonna
turn upside down because you didn't get
to you know do the one thing you know
right in your journal or whatever then
that's it
cross-purposes with the entire intention
behind the in time the whole thing yeah
I'd be constantly trying to get in
Russell Westbrook's head and mess up his
routine you know what I mean I'd be like
what could you do to get inside that
loop in that guy's head right because
then it's a house of cards yes right
yeah so I want to round this out okay
and and end it in a minute but I wanted
I want to like do that by talking about
service which kind of brings it back to
the 12 steps right yeah like my
underrated my own step divinely-inspired
yeah my primary purpose is to stay sober
and help another alcoholic like my job
is to be of service and the more that I
can inject not just in that formal
construct but everything that I do if I
can if I can come from a service
perspective and enter situations from
from a position of what can I contribute
and how can i enhance somebody else's
life rather than like what am I going to
extract out of this to benefit myself
sure my life goes better you know and
and that's you know something that you
explore and in the book as well like how
can how can we be like part of this
whole equation of being still is about
giving yeah and and one way to think
less about yourself is just like think
more about other right well you know and
self-obsession is the enemy of stillness
right yeah and the path out of self
obsession is to avail yourself to
another yes then did you read the new
David Brooks book the second mountain no
not yeah it's some interviews with
recently though and it's pretty amazed
pretty fascinating yeah I think that
it's like oh because what happens is you
climb the first mountain which is
getting what you want and you realize
it's nice but it's not actually what you
want
what you want is connection and to be a
value to people and to be a part of the
community and to do things that matter
you know and I think people think you
have to do this on this grand scale but
it's you know maybe it's just like I
know being like a dad's my number one
priority or so like I think just just
getting out of your own head a little
bit getting not making your ambition the
primary driving force in your life being
a little bit more like Fred Rogers yeah
what about a human being right yeah
maybe should be a saint
I wonder if that'll I wonder if five
hundred years from now we have a little
distance that can happen it would be
cool I'll guess I wasn't Catholic so
maybe you can't well a different kind of
Saint
yeah certainly a secular certainly
somebody who's who carried a very high
consciousness yes yes I never thought
about the the flashing yellow light yeah
explain that a little bit well it's a
fuel if you watch Mister Rogers you
people remember the singing they
remember the sweatshirt the sweater and
the shoes and the train but the first
thing that you see when the show starts
is actually a flashing yellow traffic
light not like a yellow light like it's
about to turn red it's the warning like
railroad tracks ahead
be careful slowdown hazardous road and
that's like a powerful symbol and then
when you think about what this show is
the show is all about slowing down right
his tone so deliberately slow yes almost
uncomfortably so and then you realize
it's like Oh cuz I'm not the audience
the audience is a child who's never
heard any of these basic things before
and and it's it I there's a scene she
talks about where he's like the first
time I turned on a television I didn't
know what it was and there were these
people throwing pies at each other you
know he was like they were throwing pies
at each other it's like magical
technology and we were using it to do
that and I think his point was like what
if we use this to give the world more of
what it needs
it's not more of what it doesn't need
and that was his mission you know I know
one gets into children's tell well I
guess some people do now like
Nickelodeon or whatever but you know one
gets into children's public access
television to get rid right and that's
something I talk to authors about what
it's like if if you're you're but like
because people go I would like you to
write a book with me or write a book for
me or mark at my book and I feel like
what are your goals what are you trying
to do kind of like you know my number
one goal is to be North Times bestseller
number both sell two million copies
whenever I hear a number of copies that
people want to sell nope but no mention
of the idea that they want a birth into
the world yes but which is problematic
enough it's helped them but I go like if
your thing is to make money you already
[ __ ] up like this is the worst way to
make money like this is the worst way
but uh
you know it's like you're selling
something that takes you're selling so
many people that to people that they
actively don't want do you know what I
mean and so or that only appeals to like
a small fraction of humanity I'm not
saying books don't have an enormous
impact and haven't changed the world and
clearly I believe that some by true my
own experiment it is such an ego trigger
like I have a book and that book is in a
bookstore so I must be important yeah or
that I wanted a seven-figure advance or
what like so I gave this talk to the
some people of the Naval Command last
month in DC and and I was talking about
this too is like if you're but it's like
clearly you didn't choose the Navy to
get rich and to be famous and yet we
made decisions it's like oh but this
command is more high-profile or you know
like this one comes with a cooler car
and it's like so you're you've made a
very clear statement consciously or
unconsciously about your intention and
your priority when you chose this thing
you know so why are you know if you
chose classical music why are you mad
that you
have 20 million Instagram followers
you chose a niche so like be consistent
about it and your lack of consistency is
is what's causing your spiritual angst
yeah I mean it goes back to the
complexity of being human right we're
still compelled by those base desires
for power money status well and we're
comparing ourselves to other people
always which is like you know the thief
of joy as they don't really spelled said
right yeah it's like okay like I just
have to remind myself of that comment
I'm not saying you can't make money
writing books but clearly that's not
what's the most important thing to me or
I would be writing screenplays or I'd be
writing advertising copy mm-hmm you know
or you know I would not be writing at
all because this is not I'd be making
you know I'd be a vlogger or there's so
many other things you could do it's like
I chose writing because actually I
didn't choose writing writing chose me
that's what I do that's you know and the
other job that would be perfectly suited
for you just doesn't exist in our era
which is the idea of the philosopher who
is consultant to the leader yes sure how
do we get back to that yeah I mean we
guys a few of those yes yeah it would be
it would be relieving it would be a
relief to know there was some even
conflicted hypocritical philosophers in
Trump's court but there are not you know
what I mean it's the team of vipers
instead but yeah I do I do like that I
would I would like that especially
because it's like you know maximum
influence minimum minimal inconvenience
sent an utter lack of accountability but
I yeah look it's like I write I just
remind myself it's like I write these
books because I think I have something
to say and that and that
look I go I write the books about the
things that I write and I think they're
important I am I'm not mark Manson is on
a different path in a different calling
and I'm not denigrating his thing at all
I'm just saying like we each have a lane
and you know what some people are lying
back
and some people are quarterbacks and
some people are you know distance
runners and some are sprinters like
there's a biological component there's a
you know a training component there's a
personality component and you go like
this is the Vista X you know the Roman
world was very strict and its hierarchy
so you know there there's downsides to
that which is that like they said
there's a slave hierarchy but there was
also this comfort in the idea of like
Marcus Aurelius didn't want to be
Emperor not really you know he would
have rather been a book worm but he's
like that's what happened right so I
have to do my best to do the best at
that but you as a writer I mean you're a
living example of somebody who is in
love with the process because you don't
turn out books of your caliber
year after year I mean you come out with
a book every year as soon as you finish
you're into the next one that no cards
are out and like you're like you're you
it's a good thing harder than writing
it's a it's torturous and it's painful
and you have a practice and a diligence
about it because you love doing it like
you love the process of grappling with
these ideas and trying to put together
these thoughts in in a cohesive
narrative yeah and but so my output is
either a sign that it's everything that
things are very right or the things are
very wrong and I think it's both you
don't put a book out then what what does
that say about who you are yeah why
can't I enjoy it why do I have to like
writing a book also such as oh I can't
say all right yeah so let's let's leave
everyone with a couple just key you have
things about stillness like if someone's
listening to this they're gonna pick up
the book they're gonna read it but like
what like what are the core concepts
that you want somebody to walk away with
after reading this book well first just
this idea that stillness is really
important that stillness is where we
feel happiness where we feel contentment
where our best work comes from where we
make good decisions where we're at peace
do you know what I mean that looks like
we knows when we've experienced
stillness it was wonderful
why is it so rare and how can we build
habits and ideas and habits and
practices and set priorities that make
it less less of an accident and more of
a an intentional outcome I'm not saying
it's like oh this is good like you know
stillness is good for your work so go
get more stillness but it's like why are
these wonderful moments so rare and it's
not about going on a possitive
meditation retreat or pulling a
geographic or doing anything extreme
it's about building habits that create
more of these moments in your daily life
yes and and having a set of people you
admire who achieved it that you look to
and yes some of the habits I mean yet
setting a routine it's being active it's
actively experiencing nature in some way
oh one of my favorite exercises from the
Stoics is and the most beautiful lines
from the stove's it's not Marcus
Aurelius describing the Colossus of
Rhodes or you know the aqueducts or the
Colosseum it's Marcus Aurelius writing
about you know the way a stock of grain
is bending under its own weight or you
know the sound that plucking a grape
makes or you know the he's talking about
the furrowed brow of the lion and so he
would have seen that in like some the
horrible carnage of the Colosseum do you
know what I mean but what he's he's
spotting he's actively looking for
beauty amidst what would have been a
violent disgusting you know dark place
right and so actively doing that you
know it's not like oh look at that
pretty sunset it should be like look at
the lines on this table like how did you
know yeah the Lord finding it in the
ordinary and that's being present of
course you know I think of people that
embody this quality as being like a
lighthouse right like when somebody who
exudes stillness or is a living example
of this walks into a room like you'll
know it you feel it and you're like what
is it about
that person because they're standing in
their strength in their power and
they're like a they're like a magnet
that everyone is drawn to and I think
we're we're kind of more prone to be
chasing attention from other people like
we're running after it rather than
gathering our strength and our resources
so that we can stand in it and attract
what we want into our life rather than
chasing it when that's why the the cover
was really hard to crack on this book
and it's a son because I think it
radiates out and I wanted it to be
something masculine because I felt like
it's like you can imagine so you write
this book and they give you all the
template covers they want the font is
they're gonna be like but it's you know
it's like some stones tacks stacked on
top of each other it's a crystal it's a
it's a stone dropping into some water
you know or it's like a statue of Buddha
it's like there's like ten like sort of
Zen images and they all tend to be
pretty feminine nothing there's a
problem with that but I do think it's
signals to people to a large percent of
the other population that this is not
for them and in fact it's like them who
needs it most right and yeah there's a
Marcus quote he's having more about
honesty but he says like you will know
the honest and good person because they
are like a smelly coat in the room he's
like you will you know when they're in
the room with you and I think that's
true like even even if if you were in an
airport and the Dalai Lama walked in in
street clothes I think you would know
mm-hmm I think you'd know if you saw
Jesus I think you'd know if you saw some
I think Socrates Socrates was at your
neighbor's house you'd feel it and it
would be a modern current living example
of that I mean this is like in the world
this is a bad one because it's political
but and I'm yeah I think they could say
this even if you despise every one of
his policies but I think Obama has that
I think he was and he talks about this
he's like I think it was cuz my mother
was pregnant with me in Hawaii and she
would just sort of sit on the beach and
look at the ocean while he was in the
womb yeah there he just had he was
unflappable and you think
about the [ __ ] that got thrown at them
it almost makes it more impressed you
know even if you hate him you're like
why did we never get to him
yeah you know I so I think he's a pretty
great example I would agree with that I
mean I think I think tick Matt Vaughn is
alive so you you know he has it
right but you know I'm thinking of
people who are like in the culture you
know like like Sam Harris is a pretty
good example of that is somebody who who
although he was when he gets like is an
argument yeah he'll he and he'll admit
yeah he'll admit when he falls prey to
that but in general he's able to
maintain a level of equanimity under
duress I think so in a way that I think
is is interesting yeah I think so I
think there's some athletes that you
know have it in fleeting moments we see
it it's but it it's one of those things
where it's like you know it when you see
it uh-huh
you know you don't have it tangible so
yeah right and maybe trying to describe
when you and you're like when you see it
you're like I want I want to be near
that person yeah yeah are you you're
walking along the ocean at night or
you're walk out on the street after the
snow is falling you're the first one is
like this this is it you know but then
look more like the people and watching
the artist is present then realized but
that's my phone yeah you know or oh you
know what like let's go skiing tomorrow
I mean you know or I should take a photo
of this you know it's tough being human
man it is it is tough I like my wife I
remember I was er do you want to go in
the pool and I was like yes we were in
the pool and you want to do laps she was
like we can just be in the pool that's
right that is I think that's it in a
nutshell right yeah is it not yes cool
well uh let's put a pin in it all right
man next time yeah I really do love this
book and you did a great job it's gonna
help a lot of people it's quite an
accomplishment I love all your books but
I really think that this is like taking
it to a new and
exciting place for a lot of people and
I'm excited to see what happens with it
so stillness is the key comes out
September 28th there's Tober 1st October
1st ok yeah excellent and if people want
to connect with Ryan the best place to
do that Ryan holiday dotnet and your
sign up for your newsletter you send out
monthly reading recommendations yeah or
just daily stoic daily stuff daily
Starcom yes right excellent
yeah and pick up the new book please
alright man thanks for uh thanks for
talking me come back and do it again I
will all right peace
[Music]